this is the old Royal Naval College in
Greenwich the world heritage-listed site
that most Americans and let's be honest
most Brits Noah's that place that got
blown up in Thor too but that blowing up
would have been a heck of a lot
different if it'd have happened a couple
of decades earlier see for many years
this was a working Royal Navy training
base that's why it's got the name old
royal naval college I start centuries
ago there were sailors being trained
here up until the mid 90s and well the
Royal Navy has nuclear submarines
nuclear submarines have nuclear reactors
nuclear reactors need people to run them
and so what do you do if you are the
Royal Navy and you need sailors to run
your nuclear reactors well you build a
nuclear reactor in the basement of a
seventeenth-century building just miles
from the center of London seriously
right here somewhere in this complex are
in the basement of this the King William
building there was a working nuclear
reactor for many years from 1963 to the
mid 90s at the time when Greenwich
called itself a nuclear-free zone this
area was specifically exempted and why
was on our outcry well first of all not
only people knew about it the Royal Navy
is quite good at operational security
and secondly well despite the words
nuclear reactor being quite scary it was
only a tiny reactor it reduced ten
kilowatts that's enough to power about
five electric kettles and the amount of
fuel and waste produced are actually
pretty tiny there would never have been
ashin novel here but well if Thorin
invaded a couple of I don't know what
for did I haven't seen the movie if Thor
had invaded a couple of decades earlier
who knows there might have been a bit
more radioactivity to power his hammer I
like I said I haven't seen the movie
this is the first of the video is
powered by the things you sent in thanks
very much David and Ali who tipped me
off about the reactor in the middle of
Greenwich
you